prêt pour en débattre rémy rebeyrotte
débuté la république heures marche
troisième circonscription de
saône-et-loire bonsoy rémy rebeyrotte
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés alain
houpert sénateur les républicains de la
côte d'or
bonsoir à tous les deux on a entendu ce
témoignage plein de tristesse et de
passion évidemment de notre invité qui
dénonce en substance une forme de
scandale humanitaire vous trouvez que
c'est un jugement sévère rémy rebeyrotte
que vous ont inspiré ses propos elle
pointe clairement du doigt la
responsabilité de l'état et des
ministres
oui je voudrais simplement dire on ne
veut pas aux séries
il s'est passé à l'époque dans les mêmes
circonstances
je veux bien sûr à lever 6 à 7 personnes
toutes toutes mes condoléances pas
s'attaquer au mal que fait personne
d'ailleurs qui sont décimés à vis des
familles y sont passés par cette épreuve
ries lui est sans doute de simples
agents commis à la terre entière
parce que quand on a découvert la
maladie rappelle qu'à l'époque on
parlait depuis pour leurs clients la
solution universelle
il ya eu beaucoup pas tellement les
pauvres que c'est stupide si
naturellement à vous la tenez
c'était très compliqué comme situation
mais j'allais dire moi je voudrais pas
me rendre vraiment hommage au spawn y
ont fait le maximum même si même si
évidemment cette situation était
extrêmement et douloureuse c'est vrai
quel point surtout l'état et les
ministres du doigt c'est vrai qu'on nous
avait dit il n'y a pas besoin de masquer
un au départ justement à l'époque où son
papa est décédé il n'y a pas besoin de
masque en fait on n'en n'avait pas
clairement l on parle de mensonge
y a pas un peu de ça quand même rémy
rebeyrotte n'y avait pas de masque et on
nous disait pas en mettre en tout
simplement parce qu'il n'avait pas vous
savez des décisions du premier des
premiers
on sait y suffit qu il y avait des
points de vue extrêmement différent qui
s'exprimait certains disaient faut
absolument des masques d'autres disaient
on perd les masques ne sont pas utiles
et notamment sur la voie publique enfin
je me rappelle comme tout le monde de
cette période où il ya une extrême
confusion aussi bien d'ailleurs des
sciences que des politiques qui était
conseillé par des scientifiques
eux-mêmes disait on ne sait pas grand
chose je le rappelle
là encore nous étions tout au début 2000
hôpital lui même était en grande
difficulté
bon je ne dira sans doute des raisons
évidemment enfin il faut reconnaître si
vous voulez nous étions tous dans une
situation extrêmement content et
jusqu'au jusqu'au en filmant sévère
difficile
il a fallu que nous subissions tous pour
essayer de maîtriser
allez on perd vous vous écoutez ce
témoignage également quel est votre
sentiment vous partager la vie de rémy
rebeyrotte finalement voilà c'était le
début on a tâtonné on a pris les
mauvaises décisions mais ya pas vraiment
en substance un jeu laissait de traduire
les propos il ya pas vraiment de deux
fautes caractérisées de l'état c'est
votre avis aussi
maintenant je je je comprends la colère
et le besoin de justice de clara bouaziz
parce que le d'exécutif depuis le début
de cette épidémie nous est totalement
infantilisée l'enfermer n'a laissé ni
aux citoyens ni ni aux médecins de ville
et aux parlementaires la moindre liberté
face à ce virus
il y avait un protocole auto cole
sanitaire au total politique à suivre
sans possibilité de s'écarter
il ya un revers à cette infantilisation
c'est la responsabilité des défaillances
et des défaillances y en a eu beaucoup
énormément il ya eu les masques toutes
ces polémiques
les tests avec le calibrage des tests et
maintenant des vaccins donc on est
vraiment dans un système pervers
où toute la communication du
gouvernement depuis depuis un an est
fondée sur la peur et la méfiance est
pour nous forcer la pourquoi la peur
pour nous forcer d'adhérer sans
réfléchir à des mesures qui sont
décidées sans concertation y compris
imposées parlementaires dont c'est la
mission de réfléchir avec le
gouvernement il faut qu'il y ait un lien
entre le gouvernement et le législatif
et le parlement ça c'est très important
et je pense que le l'exécutif a raté le
coche en ne mettant pas son parlement
dans la vie c'est parce que il est
important de dans un état de faire état
nation une formation c'est faire
participer les gens c'est faire
participer des parlementaires ça n'a pas
été fait alors il ya un autre point on
va y revenir justement il ya un autre
point qui a été souvent pointé du doigt
c'est la lourdeur administrative de
notre pays une problématique soulevée
d'ailleurs par pas mal de politiques un
regard des à titre d'exemple le tweet du
maire de cannes david lisnard c'était
fin novembre est la crise due qu'au
guide révèle la folie bureaucratique
française
rémy rebeyrotte c'est une critique que
vous partagez vous savez cette prise
elle révèle surtout une chose c'est que
ce pays semble impossible réunit l'union
nationale je ne sais pas si ça existe
encore ça existait fut un temps dans
dans ce pays cette capacité si vous
voulez à se mettre tous ensemble a
hérité d'exploiter ou plan politique une
situation de crise grave
j'observe que ça n'est plus possible
c'est à dire que certains ont fait leur
lit politique d'une crise qui aurait des
tous nous rassembler pour essayer de
trouver des solutions et les devants
j'observe d'ailleurs je mets de côté les
élus locaux
parce que la plupart des élus locaux
pour eux ce sont tous ces les manches
avec les préfets pour trouver des
solutions et des solutions les plus
efficaces possibles sur le terrain pour
faire avancer à chaque étape
les solutions pour la population alors
je peux vous dire étant à l'assemblée
nationale même chose n'attendez pas
aujourd'hui hélas d'un certain nombre de
politiques au niveau national cette
capacité à dire écoutez on met de côté
les divisions on se met tous ensemble on
essaye de trouver des solutions
moi je les vis l'uci a à plusieurs
reprises et je le regrette parce que je
pense que quand on est dans un état
d'urgence sanitaire on doit trouver
ensemble normalement dès les solutions
pour avancer
donnez moi on arrive presque à la fin de
notre face à face déjà
justement vous dites et politiques
nationaux c'est bien là où le bât blesse
souvent on a entendu genre père le
président la région de rente est
concédée décrié ce n'était pas le seul
on n'a pas assez donné la main aux
régions au terrain ça a été l'un des
grands problèmes de cette crise et ça
continue d'ailleurs
évidemment on le voit tous les jours
avec la campagne de vaccination alain
houpert ça ne sert pas de leçon on
n'arrive pas à se dépêtrer de cet état
centralisé jacobins monsieur rebeyrotte
a dit que le vivre ensemble ou décider
ensemble n'existe plus mais je suis
optimiste il existe il suffit d'écouter
le parlement et ne pas être pas écouter
seulement l'assemblée nationale qui est
aux ordres du gouvernement écouter aussi
sénat
nous nous validons
l'état d'urgence c'est une situation
exceptionnelle mais nous faisons tout
pour qu'elles ne deviennent pas la règle
et puis on a parlé de la technocratie
tout à l'heure c'est une technocratie
triomphante parce que c'est elle qui
commande c'est elle qui prive les élus
locaux de leur liberté et on a vu les
départements les régions dans la
délivrance des mal cités de catastrophe
les maires les maires dans le cadre du
confinement il ya des villages qui n'ont
jamais vu un seul cadre qu vide et on
applique les mêmes rails notant certains
villages où il n'ya pas de souci où il
ya des dissociations mais vrai que dans
les métropoles
donc l'état a prévu des élus locaux de
la moindre liberté et on a vu cette
technocratie triomphante on l'a vu
pendant la période de noël où il a fallu
pas moins du premier ministre et de
trois ministres à côté de lui pour
signer la possibilité de vendre des
sapins de noël à l'extérieur donc c'est
quand même c'est quand même un ridicule
et on a vu aussi ce ridicule dans les
fameux rayon non essentiels on voyait
des rayons dans les supermarchés qui
sont complètement gâchée ne laissons pas
le pouvoir à cette technocratie qui n'a
pas la capacité humaine qu'on les éduque
faisons confiance aux parlementaires et
fait confiance aux locaux comme l'a dit
monsieur rebeyrotte c'est très important
et il vient de saône et loire il sait ce
que c'est qu'un élu local
c'est un des deux qui mouillent mouiller
la chemise qui relève ses manches et qui
est proche du du quotidien qui projet
d'habitants et souvenez-nous de la route
de campagne de monsieur mâcon qui disait
il volait une campagne horizontal il
voulait une décision horizontale y en a
vu depuis cette crise qu vite que dès
cette décision verticale et quand le
peuple gronde qu'est-ce qui fait mouche
et mâcon
il crée un comité citoyen théodule où on
désigne au au sort quelques quelques
candidats et puis quand un député ou un
mini d'un sénateur rondes débats en on
voit un ministre pour dans l'hémicycle
pour lui dire que c'est pas la bonne
question la semaine dernière je me
posais une question au premier ministre
sur les universités
il a été indigné que je puisse se poser
la question
il a jugé irresponsable
rouvrir l'université pas la question que
pose est est pas la question se pose et
je suis aussi indigné quand je vois
olivier ferrand répondre à madame
martine bonnaire cette semaine la
semaine dern mrc pardonnez moi je suis
désolé je suis obligé de vous couper à
la on perd mais on est vraiment arrivé
tout au bout de notre débat merci en
tout cas compris le respect oui pardon
je souhaite que le l'exécutif respecte
les parlementaires et les élus maires de
ce territoire qui s'appelle la france et
ça sera le nom de la femme mère si elle
a ou perdus merci également à remy
robert d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france